so last week everyone was in a bit of a
tizzy about this hot new video game the
order 1886 not only did this game get a
critical panning but headlines were
rampant about the game's paltry
single-player length this would have
been an interesting discussion about how
quality can trump quantity but as it
happens the order 1886 was actually a
bit [__] and if anything its brevity was
a godsend
but we're still left with the question
how important is game length and what
constitutes good value when we're
spending $60 the point season 3 episode
7 it's not the length it's what do you
do with it that counts console games
used to be pretty short if you had the
skills streets of rage or revenge of
shinobi could be completed in under an
hour no problem but you were never gonna
do it in under an hour the first few
times hell the first few times you
played it you probably couldn't make it
past that massive prick with the
boomerang sword that's because the home
console market was a descendant of the
arcades a world where games were
designed with the coins in your pocket
in mind games that rewarded your ability
with more value the better you got the
more time you got for quarter-scale was
connected with value but this
relationship no longer existed with the
home console conversions of these games
to play the game at home you were asked
to spend a hundred times more than the
initial asking price of the arcade
machine to play the game as much as you
wanted you had to pay around $50 the
home consoles didn't require you to pop
coins in every time you died so instead
if you died too many times he'd of the
star from the beginning and this is
where the concept of replayability
appeared games that were deemed more
valuable had high replayability they
were tough required you to hone your
skills had things to unlock and extra
challenges to accomplish so
replayability became connected with
value games were expensive and often
played by a generation which neither
worked or have much purchasing power so
the idea that a game could be were
playable give an added value to the
consumer to the point where some reviews
often gave it a score as the home
console market grew in the arcades
Shrunk game design reacted to its new
masters gamers found value in
replayability but the problem with
making difficult games was that skill
wasn't an equal playing field
and in a medium where more and more
people were picking up controllers this
caused the problem if the value of a
game was locked behind a skill wall than
a $50 game at different worth for
differently skilled players so
difficulty settings became standard
allowing players to adjust the game to
their own skill level and thus allowing
everyone to enjoy the full breadth of
content available on the cartridge CV or
disk so while in generations past it was
a return on skill investment or
replayability
that dictated a game's value now
designers had a brand new Lord to pray
to content the amount of content in a
game and our ability to get to it became
the anchor of our decision-making around
value so games were designed with more
content and with more mechanisms that
would allow everyone to get to that
content so games became easier longer
and more rich with modes new modes were
added by developers trying to get an
edge and then became normal standard for
that genre so as the years went on the
level of content we expected from a
full-price game increased and this is
where we run into trouble content is
expensive while an artist could draw a
character model for Streets of Rage and
say add a character models and modern
games require a lot more work and this
demand for more variety for more detail
is done two things first of all it's
driven the cost of development up into
the tens of millions bankrupting dozens
of companies and giving us all this DLC
bollocks we have to suffer through and
second of all and this is much more
worrying it's all but ground innovation
to a halt in the triple-a space it's
just too risky the order 1886 is the
poster boy for this suffocation a game
so beautiful and rich in detail that the
development team has seemingly no
resources to put any meaningful gameplay
in but it's not the only offender we've
had seven years of annualized
cookie-cutter Call of Duty games EA
Sports games held creative hostage with
the sheer number of modes expected in
each release while evolved reminds us of
the cost of content a game that launched
with over $100 worth of optional
[__] 2014 was a staggering year for
big budget games buckling under their
own development waste watchdogs was
generic as hell
destiny launched led the end game and
NHL an entire modes removed unity was
broken Master Chief collection was
broken
Club was broken most of them still are
but while the triple-a gamespace buckles
under its own weight and has little time
to innovate the opposite is happening in
the indie scene it's become the new
arcade a digital one with low-cost games
for you to pick through games that try
new things push design boundaries and
cater to specific groups of gamers
instead of attempting to please everyone
over the past few years we've seen in
the head after in the head while the big
budget game space has puffed and wheezed
on the consumer expectations but with
the rise of shorter replayable indie
games that cost a quarter of the price
the popularity of mobile games that cost
a bit of dollar and the absolute
curveball free-to-play is thrown into
the mix all triple-a games seem to have
left to do to justify their $60 asking
price is the cram more and more crap in
and maybe some shinier pixels they've
painted themselves into a corner by
relying on content over innovation
triple-a development has become
increasingly costly increasingly risky
and increasingly bland the order could
have broken that mold if it was a 5 hour
of game which we wrote the rulebook of
narrative driven action games but of
course it wasn't like so many big-budget
games we've seen in this console
generation it was simply overhyped
forgettable schlock this console
generation has been worryingly scant a
truly innovative games and it's only
gonna continue that way as long as
developers retain this unhealthy
obsession with content a good game is a
good game regardless of the amount of
maps or modes or pixels that eyes the
developers have to stop leaning on
production values and pure content to
try and justify the cost of their games
just like mom used to say it's not the
length what you do it it it cats